average people look at you know what it
is they don't critical think they don't
analyze your hater will make you greater
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly nothing can get in
your way
rise and shine it's an expresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message think critically over to
you Eric Thomas let's talk about what
you know again average versus phenomenal
when people who are met with opposition
what do you what do you do what do you
do with your average and what do you do
with your phenomenal I think of your
average you play into the situation you
know I'm saying so like let's say it's
perceived as negative like you go there
you know you go with all he hating on me
or she hating on me I'll give you a
prime example when I was average I saw
my wife's treatment of my gift as
opposition like yo she ain't supported
me you know I'm saying like Oh am I here
speaking you know I'm saying like every
time I speak she critiquing me you know
she never said none positive about my
presentation like every time I get
offstage if it's the best that I thought
I ever did she like what you should have
done this you shouldn't have said that
like come on you know better than that
you didn't I'm just like yo what's up
like where's the support you know that
was average you know great was she going
to work when I'm working on becoming a
motivational speaker I should go to work
every day so she supported you you got
health insurance because she had health
insurance
she got a 401k she's built up a bank
account
she got a phenomenal credit score and
got us a house with her credit score
yeah I was gonna say
no but when I was average it was like
you're not doing what I want you to do
but when I became great I realized you
know I already got 40 people that just
said that was a phenomenal message you
don't get better by people telling you
what you did right you get better by
watching the film you get better by
critiquing yourself so here's a person
who's brave enough to critique me
because somebody else might have thought
the same thing but they weren't gonna
say no to me about it you know I'm
saying so just looking at the situation
like you know don't look at it average
people look at you know what it is they
don't critical think they don't analyze
they don't they don't they don't unpack
you know I'm saying like they just see
that's blue and not go deeper into well
actually that could be whatever it is
yellow and purple whatever colors big
blue light this is what this really is
so for me
average taking everything as it was you
know victim phenomenal Victoire and
seeing possibilities seeing beyond you
know what surface that to me that's one
of the characteristics that determine a
person who's average versus somebody
who's great your hater makes you greater
if you can only learn from feedback when
it's sugar-coated for you and gift
wrapped in this perfect little bundle
then you're gonna lose most people's
self-confidence is so low that as soon
as they get any kind of negative
criticism they crumble don't let that be
you your hater will make you greater so
what you want to do is learn to love
feedback however it comes to you I had a
recent call with someone who's trying to
help me with my Instagram account and
I'm open to feedback tell you what I'm
doing wrong I want to grow this I'm
humble if I suck at something I want you
to tell me that I suck at something I
actually get weirdly excited when you
tell me that I suck at something I don't
want to hear how great I am I already
know that I'm great I want to know where
I socks that I can get better so I had
this call with there was supposed to be
a half-hour call of her helping me but
ended up spending 45 minutes of the time
helping her just helping her with her
business on where she was going because
I get curious about the people I'm
working with and I believed in them but
I want to see them grow I spent 45
minutes talking to her before I had to
hop off to another call zero
spent on me and my Instagram account and
at the end of it
she thanked me she said you know what
most people don't challenge me like this
I really love learning through debate
and most people don't push me this far
like you have today on this call I said
that's great it's amazing I'm so glad
you'd be able to grow over these 45
minutes but you need to learn to take
criticism and feedback much faster if
you only learn to learn through debate
you will lose because most people will
not have the patience to sit with you
for 45 minutes and debate with you about
why you're wrong about why you're losing
in this circumstance about why you need
to get better most people will not have
that patience and if that's the only way
that you will learn you will lose you
need to be able to learn to take
feedback in whatever way it comes to you
so somebody's sugar coating everything
insane listen I love your content I love
everything you're doing I'm a huge
supporter I've bought all your books and
t-shirts and I love every video and they
have a tiny little suggestion I think
might work that's the super sugar sugar
coated way if that's how it comes
amazing but somebody might come and say
your video suck I hate everything that
you stain for and here are the three
reasons why your content is garbage
maybe they have a point that you need to
listen to as well now that's not to say
that every single hater comment is gonna
be good for you that is gonna be
constructive and give you feedback to
get better it's not some people will
hate you just because they have
insecurities about themselves and
there's nothing you can do to make it
better but don't write off every
negative comment just because it's
negative there are kernels of truth in a
lot of those comments that you can learn
to get better your haters make you
greater now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
question of the day I want to know what
is the single biggest lesson that you
have learned from one of your haters or
critics in your life leave it down the
comments below I'm curious to find out
the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tells students why they should
write something it's like well you have
to do this assignment well why are you
writing well you need the grade it's
like no you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely deadly nothing can get in
your way so that's why you learn to
write it's like when I can't believe
that people aren't just told that it's
it's it's like it's the most powerful
weapon you can possibly provide someone
with and I mean I know lots of people
who have been staggeringly successful
and watched them throughout my life I
mean those people you don't want to have
an argument with them they'll just slash
you into pieces and then not in a
malevolent way it's like if you're gonna
make your point and they're gonna make
their point you better have your points
organized because otherwise you're gonna
look like and be an absolute idiot you
are not going to get anywhere and if you
can formulate your arguments coherently
and make a presentation if you can speak
to people if you can lay out a proposal
god people give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence raise
your standard value
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's something serene if you want
to learn more from eric thomas check out
the top fifty rules for success video
that i did on him it's right next to me
continue to believe i hope you enjoyed
today's shot a vinspresso
and i'll see you on the next video you
will not i work me Oh Joe jet you will
not work me and your Bentley you will
not work me